ردا على اسقاط طائره مسيره امريكيه موسكو
تعتبر الهجوم على اي من طائراتها اعلان
حرب على اكبر دوله نوويه
صمت ليبيه يتبع تحذيرات وكاله الطاقه
الذريه الدوليه بشان اختفاء طنين ونصف من
اليورانيوم
البرلمان الفرنسيه امام اخر فرصه اليوم
لتمرير قانون التقاعد وماكرون يهدد بحله
اذا فشل
[موسيقى]
نبدا ان نشرب مشاهدينا من قضيه اسقاط
روسيا لطائره مسيره امريكيه في البحر
الاسود حيث يتواصل التماسن بين الجانبين
حتى الان جرى اتصال بين وزير دفاع البلدين
لاحتواء الخلافه موسكو في هذا السياق حذرت
من اي خطوه امريكيه انتقاميه قد تستهدف
طائره روسيه في المجال الدولي وقال ايضا
السفير الروسي في امريكا انا طولي انتونوف
ان الهجوم على الطائرات الروسيه في مجال
جوي محايد هو اعلان حرب مفتوحه ضد اكبر
قوه نوويه اكد ايضا ان الصراع بين روسيا
وامريكا سيكون مختلفا بشكل جذري عن الحرب
غير المباشره بين البلدين في اوكرانيا
قبل ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
الوزير سرقه شويجو اكد خلال اتصال هاتفي
مع نظيره الامريكي ان روسيا ستواصل الرد
على جميع الاستفزازات المماثله لتحقيق
تحليق المسيرات الامريكيه قرب الحدود
الروسيه وان الطلعات المسيرات الامريكيه
قباله سواحل شبه جزيره القرم لها طبيعه
استفزازيه لتصعيد الوضع في منطقه البحر
الاسود واضاف شويغو ان سبب حادثه المسيره
الامريكيه هو عدم الامتثال لمنطقه تقييد
الطيران التي اعلنتها روسيا
وزير الدفاع الامريكيه لويد اوستن ان
الطيران العسكريه الامريكي سيواصل التحليق
في اطار القانون الدولي واكد اوستون ان
على روسيا تشغيل مقاتلاتها بطريقه
احترافيه وامنه
[موسيقى]
امريكيه كانت تقوم بمهمه عاديه في المجال
الجوي الدولي وحدث اصطدام مع مقاتله روسيه
هذا يعد حلقة متجدده من افعال الطيارين
الروس المتهوره في المجال الجوي
الدوليه اتصالا هاتفيا مع نظير الروسي
وكررت انه من المهم ان تكون القوه العظمى
مثالا للشفافيه والتواصل الولايات المتحده
ستواصل التحليق في اطار القانون الدولي
ومن مهام روسيا ان تشغل مقاتلاتها بطريقه
احترافيه وامنه في المجال الجوي الدولي
ونقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن مسؤولين امريكيين
قولهم ان الجيش الامريكي حذف عن بعد برامج
حساسه من المسيرات الامريكيه التي سقطت في
البحر الاسود لمنع روسيا من جمع معلومات
سريه واوضح المسؤولون ان القرار تم اتخاذه
بعد المواجهه بين المسيره الامريكيه
والمقاتلتين الروسيتين في البحر الاسود
فيما افاد مسؤول في البحريه الامريكيه
بانه لا توجد لدى الولايات المتحده اي سفن
تابعه للبحريه في البحر الاسود مما يجعل
ان اي محاوله امريكيه لانتشال حطام
المسيره امرا صعبا للغايه ويستغرق وقتا
طويلا على حد قوله
في المقابل اكد مدير الاستخبارات الخارجيه
الروسيه
اكد ان الولايات المتحده تقوم بعمليات
استطلاع ناشطه في منطقه البحر الاسود
باستخدام وسائل تكنولوجيه مختلفه وقال
نارشكين ان او ان الامريكيين يستخدمون
بنشاط كبير جميع الوسائل خصوصا الاستطلاع
البصري والاستطلاع اللاسلكي وقال سكرتير
مجلس الامن الروسي الناموسكو تحاول ايضا
العثور على حطام المسيره الامريكيه التي
سقطت امس في البحر الاسود
احتكاك روسي امريكي خطير مقاتله روسيه
مقابل مسيره امريكيه في تفاصيل الحادثه
التي وصفت بالخطيره
اصطدمت مقاتله روسيه من طراز سوخويت وانت
سفن بطائره امريكيه مسيره من طراز ام كيو
9 ريبر وقالت واشنطن ان قواتها اضطرت الى
اسقاط مسيره في البحر الاسود اما موسكو
فتقول ان الحادثه وقعت بالقرب من جزيره
القرم لكن لماذا وجدت مسيره امريكيه
بطريقه استفزت روسيا فوق البحر الاسود
المسؤولون العسكريون الامريكيون يقولون ان
الطائره المسيره كانت تقوم بعمليات
روتينيه في المجال الجوي الدولي اما
البنتاجون فاستنكر الحادثه واتهم
المقاتلات الروسيه بالقاء الوقود امام
المسيرات الامريكيه الا انه رفض الافصاح
عما اذا كانت مسيره مسلحه ام لا
المهمه التي كانت تقوم بها بينما للروس
روايه اخرى فهم ينظرون للحادث باعتباره
استفزازا موسكو نفتعمدها اسقاط المسيره
الامريكيه وقالت ان ام كيو 9 ريبر تحطمت
بعد ارتطامها بسطح البحر الاسود لاسباب
تعود لفقدانها الارتفاع بعد قيامها
بمناوره حاده واثناء تحليقها اضفت اجهزه
تعريفها في انتهاك لمنطقه الحظر الجوي ما
دفع مقاتلتين روسيتين الاعتراضها الا
انهما لم تسقطاها ولم تقتربا منها بشكل
خطير مستبعدين رغبه موسكو بالمواجهه مع
واشنطن حتى الان للولايات المتحده ولا
روسيا تمكنتا من استعاده حطام المسيره
الامريكيه الا ان هذا التصعيد الاخير حذر
منه مسؤول البلدين خاصه وانه اول مواجهه
مباشره بين الطرفين منذ بدء الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا روان حمزه العربيه
ميدانيا افاد مسؤول عسكري بريطاني بان
معارك ضخمه شرق اوكرانيا كبدت روسيا خسائر
فادحه مقدرا عدد قتلى وجرحى مجموعه فاغنر
والقوات الروسيه في باخموت ما بين 20 الف
مقاتل وثلاثين الف هذه التكلفه الباهظه
حسب المسؤول البريطاني هي ثمن التقدم
لحوالي 25 كيلو متر فقط داخل فخموتو
يتطابق هذا مع تصريحات الجنرال مارك ميلي
رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه الامريكيه
الذي قال ان القوات الروسيه حققت تقدما
طفيفا في باخد لكن بتكلفه بشريه هائله
مشيرا الى ان هناك جهودا مستمره لبناء
الجيش الاوكراني ومساعدته للدفاع عن
اوكرانيا
في الوقت الحالي هناك قتال عنيف في
باخموتو ومحيطها الروس يحققون تقدما
تكتيكيا صغيرا لكن بتكلفه باهظه بينما لا
يزال الخط الامامي ثابتا نسبيا مع تبادل
كبير للقصف المدفعي دون تحقيق مكاسب هناك
جهود كبيره ومستمره لبناء الجيش الاوكراني
من حيث المعدات والذخيره والتدريب في
مجموعه من البلدان بهدف تمكين اوكرانيا من
الدفاع عن نفسها
سيطرت على الجانب الشرقي من المدينه ليصبح
النهر الذي يقسم المدينه الى نصفين خط
المواجهه المباشره بين الطرفين
كذلك اعلنت قوات فاجنر في وقت سابق عن
افتتاح 58 مركزا للتجنيد في المدن الروسيه
فيما يبدو للدفع بمزيد من المقاتلين في
المعركه المصيريه بالنسبه اليها وموسكو
ومع استمرار القتال على جانبي النهر يستمر
الجانبان بالتراشق بالمعلومات والصور
معلومات ما زالت غير مؤكده حتى يثبت العكس
قلى ثلاثه مسؤولين اسرائيليين واوكرانيين
وفخام نقله موقع اكسيوس قالوا ان اسرائيل
وافقت مؤخرا على تراخيص تصدير لبيع
المحتمل لانظمه تشويش مضاده للطائرات بدون
طيار ويمكن ان تساعد اوكرانيا على مواجهه
الطائرات الايرانيه المسيره التي
استخدمتها روسيا خلال هذه الحرب فيما زعم
المسؤولون الاوكرانيون ان توفير انظمه
الاسلحه لاوكرانيا هو في مصلحه اسرائيل
لان ايران قادره على الحصول على معلومات
حول كيفيه اداء الطائرات بدون الطيار ومن
ثم اجراء تحسيناته وقال مسؤول اسرائيلي
كبير لاكسوس ان احد اسباب موافقه اسرائيل
على التراخيص وامكانيه رؤيه اداء انظمه
الدفاع ضد الطائرات الايرانيه بدون طيار
نقلت وكاله الاعلام الروسيه عن رئيس
النظام السوري بشار الاسد قوله ان بلاده
سترحب باي مقترحات من روسيا لاقامه قواعد
عسكريه جديده او زياده عدد قواتها في
سوريا كما شدد الاسد على ان الوجود
العسكري الروسي في بلاده لا يتعين عليه ان
يكون مؤقته
تتابعنا بعض الفاصل
خفر السواحل الصينيه يدخل المنطقه
المتنازع عليها مع اليابان في بحر الصين
الجنوبي
اهلا بكم من جديد تنطلق اليوم في العاصمه
الموريتانيه
بمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي ويبحث المؤتمر
على مدى يومين مستجدات القضيه الفلسطينيه
وتطورات الوضع في مالي والساحل وقضايا
الاقليات المسلمه عبر العالم كما سيتم بحث
جهود مواجهه التطرف العنيف والاسلام فوبيا
اعلن الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني عن اسعاف في
57 فلسطينيا خلال عمليه اقتحام الجيش
الاسرائيلي والمستوطنين في منطقه قبر يوسف
ومخيم بلاطه شرق نابلس واظهرت مقاطع مصوره
تعزيزات عسكريه اسرائيليه متجهه لقريه كفر
قليل في فلسطين بالتزامن مع مرور عدد من
سيارات الاسعاف باتجاه مخيم بلاطه
وفي لبنان اعلنت قوه الامم المتحده
المؤقته يونيفال بانها لم تلاحظ اي عبور
للخط الازرق بين لبنان واسرائيل في الايام
الاخيره كما حصلت اليونيفيل الطرفين على
ضبط النفس والحفاظ على الاستقرار وضعت
ايضا الى استخدام اليات اليونيفير للتنسيق
والارتباط لتجنب سوء الفهم وتقليل
التوترات
اعلنت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
اختفاء عشر اسطوانات تحوي نحو طنين ونصف
من اليورانيوم الطبيعي من موقع معلن في
ليبيا به تركيزات لليورانيوم الخام واوضحت
الوكاله الذريه في بيان ان الموقع لا يخضع
حاليا لسيطره الهيئه النوويه الليبيه
وكانت الزياره وكان مقرر كانت مقرره العام
الماضي لكنها تاجلت لاسباب امنيه الوكاله
اكدت انها ستجري مزيدا من اجراءات التحقيق
الاصطداح ملابسات ازاله هذه المواد
وموقعها الحالي وحضرت الوكاله من ان عدم
معرفه مكان هذه المواد ربما يشكل خطرا
اشعاعيا ويثير كذلك مخاوف تتعلق بالامان
النووي
اوقفت السلطات المغربيه ثلاثه عناصر من
داعش يشتبه في قيامهم بقتل شرطي عثر على
جثته متفحمه مطلع مارس الجاري قرب الدار
البيضاء وفقا لبيان مديريات الامن الوطني
المغربيه فان المتهمين بقتل الشرطي
والاستيلاء على سلاحه ومتعلقاته هؤلاء
كانوا يخططون للسطو على احدى المؤسسات
البنكيه لتمويل مخططهم الارهابي داخل
البلاد
ايام حاسمه في فرنسا مع اقتراب موعد
التصويت النهائي على مشروع قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد الموجه الثامنه من
الاحتجاجات تخرج هذه المره من المربع
الامني في باريس حيث توجد مراكز حساسه مثل
وزاره الخارجيه ومقر البرلمان لذلك رفعت
الشرطه درجه التاهب الامني وقامت باغلاق
هذا الجسر الذي يؤدي الى قصر الاليزي لمنع
المتظاهرين من عبوره الشرطه الفرنسيه صنفت
هذا اليوم بانه يحمل تهديدا عاليا وقالت
مصادر امنيه ان 1400 من مفتعل الشغب
يشاركون في تظاهرات باريس وانه تم نشر
الاف عناصر الشرطه وقرابه 1700 عسكري من
ضمنهم عناصر في الحرس الجمهوري لحمايه
المربع الامني الحشد الامني الكبير حد من
اعمال العنف جزئيا لكنه لم يمنعها
الاشتباكات وقعت مع الشرطه بعد قيام
متظاهرين بتحطيم اللوحات الاعلانيه واشعال
ح اويات القمامه المتكدسه في الشوارع
فاستخدمت الشرطه الغاز المسيل للدموع
واوقعت بعض الاصابات عاد الهدوء فكانت
فرصه بعض المتعبين لاخذ استراحه قصيره
انا متعبه نامل ان يستمع السيد مكروء
الينا لاننا سئمنا انا اتظاهر منذ ان كان
عمري 15 عاما هذا كثير وتعتبر احزاب
اليسار ان المعركه طويله وسيناريو مواصله
التظاهر قائم حتى اذا مر مشروع القانون
اعتقد انه يجب اصلاح نظام التقاعد لكن ليس
بالطريقه التي تقترحها الحكومه وتبدو
الحكومه اقرب الى اعتماد القانون من
الرضوخ لضغط الشارع متسلحه بمواد دستوريه
تسمح بتمريره اذا فشل تصويت مجلس النواب
يوم السادس عشر من مارس فادي الدهوك
العربيه باريس
وفي بريطانيا المجاوره شارك 100 الالاف من
العمال بينهما المدرسون والاطباء وعاملوه
قطار الانفاق شاركوا في اضراب عن العمل
للمطالبه بزياده الرواتب رواتب الاضرابات
هذه تتزامن مع تقديم وزير الخزانه جريمه
هاند لميزانيات العمل قدم
موعد الاحتجاجات هذه ليست صدفه 400 الف
عامل من موظفي القطاع العام من بينهم عمال
مترو الانفاقنا في لندن يضربون عن العمل
تزامنا مع اعلان الميزانيه العامه في مجلس
العموم تحاول النقابات من خلال هذه
الاحتجاجات والاضات الضغط على الحكومه من
اجل رفع اجورهم وتخليصهم من اعباء البلاد
الاقتصاديه التي يقولون انها اصبحت سيئه
للغايه
[تصفيق]
انا اشارك في الاضراب حقيقه لكل ما يحدث
في هذا البلد ليس فقط من اجل المعلمين
ولكن لكافه العاملين في البلاد
انا هنا اليوم لادعم والدتي لانها مدرسه
دائما ما تتاخر ولا تصل المنزل الا بعد
حلول الليل
وزير الماليه في مجلس العموم اليوم رد على
الغاضبين من الميزانيه العامه بضريبه على
ارباح الشركات وباجراءات اجتماعيه قلم
تتخذها حكومه يمنيه محافظه
[تصفيق]
بسبب العوامل الدوليه المتغيره وتدابير
التي اتخذتها لن تدخل بريطانيا في ركود
هذا العام
لكن لا يبدو ان المحتاجين هنا مقتنعون
بالموازنه الجديده حيث يصلون على ان موظفي
القطاع العام هم جديرون برفع اجورهم
اضرابات واحتجاجات اعطت فرصه للاحزاب
السياسيه المعارضه وعلى راسها حزب العمال
لنسب الوضع الاقتصادي المتردي لسياسات
تقول انها فاشله من قبل حزب المحافظين
الحاكم منذ اكثر ما يزيد على عقد من الزمن
من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
قال لنا خفر السواحل الصينيه عن دخوله
مياهها جزر بحر الصين الشرقي وهي المنطقه
المتنازع عليها بين بكين وطوكيو لمواجهه
ما وصفه خفر السواحل الصيني بالتوغل
اليابني في المياه الاقليميه كما اوضح
ايضا ان دخولهم للمنطقه جاء بهدف حمايه
السياده الصينيه
والان بخبر عاجل مصادر العربيه في تقديم
حاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه لاستقالته
متابعه سببه الفيضانات التي ضربت جنوب
تركيا بمقتل عده اشخاص اضافه لفقدان اخرين
ما زالت السلطات تبحث عنهم حيث شهدت
المنطقه التي ضربها الزلزال هطول او
هطولات مطريه كبيره خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه
بعد الزلزال فيضانات تضرب مناطق بجنوب
تركيا
الفيضانات ضربت ولايه
المعلومات تؤكد وقوع قتل السوريين واتراك
بينهم اطفال
كميات الامطار التي هطلت على الولايتين
تراوحت بين 111 الى 136 ملليمترا في المتر
مربع
بعض الصور اظهرت السيوله تجرف اناسا
وسيارات في الولايتين
[موسيقى]
ابرزها انقاذ طفله وامراه في اللحظات
الاخيره
[موسيقى]
وبمقاطعه ولايه كاليفورنيا تجري عمليات
اجلاء للسكان بسبب فيضانات ناجمه عن
عواصفات
[موسيقى]
النشره تذكير بالعناوين
ردا على اسقاط طائره مسيره امريكيه موسكو
تعتبر الهجوم على اي من طائراتها اعلان
حرب على اكبر دوله نوويه
صمت ليبي يتبع تحذيرات وكاله الطاقه
الذريه الدوليه بشان اختفاء طنين ونصف من
اليورانيوم
الفرنسيه امام اخر فرصه اليوم لتمرير
قانون التقاعد وماكرون يهدد بحله اذا
اراكم على راس الساعه الى اللقاء